Google cloud max 2017 hosted more talks
detailing the future of cloud than you
can shake a stick at if you didn't get a
chance to catch you fango session on
device machine learning tensorflow on
android then stay tuned because here's
the recap by combining tensorflow with
your mobile applications you can create
magical AI experiences for your users
based on their custom data sets
this is tricky though since today's
mobile devices don't have enough power
to train AI models not to mention that
it takes terabytes of high-quality
training data to build a new model from
scratch the solution then is to split
the difference
leveraging the power of the cloud to
drive your mobile experience creating
new machine learning models is extremely
resource intensive so the most practical
approach is to use cloud ml to train
your tensor flow data in the cloud and
then deploying your trained model on
your iOS Android raspberry pi devices a
great example of this is adding
customized image recognition to your
mobile app who works in real-time and
offline we start by gathering the
training data which includes the objects
we want to recognize in lots of
variations multiple angles different
lighting different backgrounds and
orientations the images of each object
gets stored in its own Google Cloud
Storage folder ready for use in training
the model training a brand new model
from scratch is a time and resource
intensive process so we're going to
cheat by using cloud ml we can leverage
a technique known as transfer learning
which lets us alter the final layer of
Google's massive 48 layer image
recognition model called Inception v3
which handles categorization and
recognition of objects by leveraging the
existing model we can train on fewer
examples and in far less time now once
your model has been trained you need to
optimize it before incorporating it into
your app and newly trained model is
typically around 80 Meg's so we want to
trim that down before putting it on a
device to start with we can remove parts
of the model which we use only for
training which we can't be used on those
devices anyway we can shrink it even
more using a technique called
quantization here we take the 32-bit
floating-point values used to represent
each pixel in an image and reduce it to
8-bit
while this is well see the neural
network is designed to take fuzzy input
into account when doing identification
so we can lose significant image quality
without sacrificing accuracy using this
approach alone we can reduce our model
by 4x bringing it down to about 20 mechs
now when our optimizations are complete
we can deploy our model now keep in mind
that the model itself is still 20 Meg's
so while you can package it directly
within your app you may want to make it
available as a separate download check
out the full session video to see you
func demonstrate his amazing candy
sorter demo and learn more about how you
can use tensorflow and ml to create
magical experiences in mobiles apps and
if you want more recaps on great next
content make sure to check out the rest
of our playlist and don't forget the
next world tour coming soon to city near
you
[Music]